на сьогодні як ми розцінюємо
азербайджан є одне з найвищої
культурних країн, які є пріоритетом
розвитку держави України та
нас багато університетів плідно
співпрацюють у частині вищої освіти
із заду жіночими університетами наприклад
в почалася ця історія були перерви
було
відновлення співпраці у нас щодо
спільної підготовки бакалаврів нова
історія почалася 2018 року
з дуже перспективних університетів
полтавська політехніка імені Юрія
кондратюка підписала
між невський договір з ес та британським
державним університетом нафти
промисловості з підготовки з подвійної
підготовки бакалаврів та
це була нова історія у розвитку
українські університети входять до
українське
або жіночі освітні центри в
тому університеті в якому раніше
ректором був яскравіший за лідерську політехніку
також була відкрита українська за баранську
центр
за біжанським слов'янським університетом
колеги були у нас у гостях і ми маємо
дуже плідна співпраця з його
жіночою діаспорою в тому числі і по
підготовці студентів
ми брали участь у 2017 році у
азербайджанської виставки як
популяризація українське почту
в принципі
українська освіта в принципі
напевно вже виникла потреба
все-таки повторити таку співпрацю
бо якби жіночі університети
та українські університети суттєво
рушили вперед і є чому дивитись
наприклад такі досліди вже цього року
були ми теж виїжджали до країн де
представляли досягнення українських
університету ви знайомилися з досвідом
інших країнах, наприклад, його зображення
можна було таке зробити ще раз
повторюсь що сьогодні
зельман входить у топ тих країн з
якими українські університети
українська вища освіта
хоче і прагне налагоджувати подальше
взаємовигідне співробітництво